[Music]
actually marvel's morbius was to be
released at the end of january but
unfortunately that's not going to happen
as those responsible announced a few
days ago the film is now to be released
on april 1st 2022 more than two months
after the originally planned date the
idea for the blockbuster which is
peppered with many horror elements
originally comes from marvel but in
cinematic terms it is part of sony's
spider-man universe the focus is on dr
michael morbius who suffers from a
serious blood disease and wants to help
not only himself but also other victims
as a result the scientists conduct a
self-experiment in which he injects
himself with radioactive bad blood at
first it seems that the experiment has
succeeded and morbius is cured however
it soon turns out that the
self-experiment has caused a dark abyss
in morbius so that he now needs human
blood to survive in the eponymous film
by director danielle espinoza the inner
conflict between the actually
good-natured scientist who is still part
of him and the bloodthirsty vampire will
be explored of course the movie is
especially interesting for fans who have
already seen the spider-man movies with
tom holland as the homecoming villain
adrian tombs already appeared in the
morbius trailer particularly after no
way home and its brilliant finale many
fans must be eagerly awaiting morbius in
fact there are two reasons that sony
signs for the postponement of the
blockbuster on the one hand the
competition to no way home which is
still the biggest box office hit in over
two years and on the other hand the
pandemic which obviously does not make
it easy for many viewers around the
world to visit the local movie theater
we can only hope that the april first
release date will indeed be met
since 2019 the superhero series the
umbrella academy has been captivating
fans with its black humor and quirky
characters after the release of season 2
in july 2020 there are now increasing
demands for a third season the follow-up
has been in production since november
2020 and is now coming into focus with
new character posters the action is to
be said in the hotel oblivion which was
introduced in volume 3 of the comics it
has been known for a while who exactly
the members of sparrow academy are but
now they can finally be seen in pictures
for the first time ben is once again
embodied by justin h man but due to the
new timeline he is slightly altered
joining him are his colleagues justin
corless marcus brittany altford is fake
jake epstein as alfonso genesis
rodriguez as sloane and cassie david as
james barrow number seven this cycronium
cube named christopher its strength lies
in its telekinetic abilities and it also
acts as a sort of oracle for the family
as illustrated at the end of the second
season the members of the umbrella
academy meet up with the sparrow academy
in the present day which in turn is a
superhero squad put together by sir
reginald hargreaves when exactly season
3 of the umbrella academy will be
released on netflix is currently unknown
actually dc's the flash won't be
released in theaters until november but
there are already a few rumors
circulating that pack a punch there's a
risk of spoilers here as the leak
contain far reaching information about
the flash and the future of the dcu if
they prove to be true of course we
cannot yet be too certain but at least
the well-known leaker my time to shine
hello published some information about
the flash the source is actually quite
trustworthy after all the leaker also
had a good nose for spiderman no way
home they explained on twitter that they
had seen a clip of the flash and that
big changes in the dcu were imminent in
the course of the storyline the flash is
expected to join a newly formed justice
league which in addition to him will
consist of supergirl and shazam and will
also be joined by wonder woman and bad
girl shelzam director andy f sandberg
did not really confirm the new rumor but
at least affirms that anything could
happen according to the leaker's report
ben affleck as batman and henry cavill
superman will no longer be part of the
cast the two would have their presumably
last appearance and the flash overall
they want to completely obliterate zack
snyder's work and actors of man of steel
justice league and batman vs superman
had never existed quite a tough cut the
dcu is in four of the rumors are true in
any case we will keep our eyes on ears
open for more details on the upcoming
the flash the movie is expected to be
released on november 4th 2022
keanu reeves is starring in matrix
resurrections which is currently in
theaters especially die hard fans of the
now four park film series were pretty
disappointed by the story and it is not
doing much better at the box office the
reasons may be debatable yet for keanu
reeves it will definitely continue with
the production of john week 4 while
another project with reeves in the
leading role could soon be on the
horizon as well the talk is of the
series the devil in the white city which
is to be an adaption of the book of the
same name by eric larson originally
leonardo dicaprio was said to play the
lead role however as deadline magazine
now reports keanu reeves is believed to
be negotiations with the people in
charge at the heart of the originally
true story are the two men daniel h
burnham and henry h holmes whereas
burnham is an excellent architect with
great vision the charming dr holmes is
in reality a cold-blooded serial killer
sometimes referred to as the first of
his kind in the united states most fans
hope that reeves will embody exactly
this serial killer and that another
candidate will be found to cast burnham
he would then also follow in the direct
footsteps of leonardo dicaprio who
bought the rights to the book series
back in 2010 and wanted to play holmes
himself in a movie adaption in the
meantime many things have changed
especially the complex story from the
time of the chicago world's fair in 1893
is no longer to be told in a condensed
form in the film but more extensively in
a series in fact scossesi who was
originally supposed to direct is now
working behind the scenes as a producer
just like his colleague dicaprio however
with little children directed outfield a
new man has already been found to direct
when and with which other actors this
series will be shot and whether reeves
will even sign the contract remains to
be seen
the anticipation for christopher nolan's
upcoming film oppenheimer is already
evident almost a year and a half before
release one of the most important
reasons for this is the cast which is
bursting with well-known stars so far a
number of names have already been
confirmed including zillion murphy as
controversial scientists j robert
oppenheimer emily blunt as his wife
catherine robert downey jr as lewis
strauss and matt damien as lieutenant
general leslie groves who was the
military leader of the manhattan project
then later in december rami malek joined
the cast as an as yet unknown scientist
along with ben safety as the hungarian
scientist edward teller florence pew
plays the u.s psychiatrist gene tadlock
who is not only a devoted member of the
communist party but also had a long
lasting love affair with oppenheimer
just a few days ago another new member
joined the cast namely he was actor josh
hartnett who had his breakthrough in
halloween age 20 in 1998 but has not
really started any major hollywood
production since the 2010s content wise
has already mentioned nolan's
oppenheimer centers around the manhattan
project which was the code name for the
development of the atomic bomb first
used in 1945 during world war ii various
scientists were involved in this most
notably of course the project scientific
director robert oppenheimer we are
definitely excited about the current
nolan production and look forward to the
movie which is expected to be released
on july 21st 2023
after several appearances as captain
america and the mcu and as hugh in the
crime film knives out u.s actor chris
evans could soon be ready to make his
next move according to deadline magazine
the 40 year old evans is currently in
talks for a leading role in as yet
untitled biopic the role in question is
that of gene kelly who was one of the
great u.s stars in the post-war era in
addition to activities as a producer
actor and singer kelly was best known
for his dancing skills his most famous
appearance was probably in the movie
musical singing in the rain which was
released in 1952 and is still quite well
known today in the biopic the emphasis
is supposed to be on that very ear as
the movie tells the story of a 12 year
old boy working on film sets in los
angeles unfortunately making friends
turns out to be a bit difficult and so
the boy imagines a friendship with gene
kelly who's currently working on his
next film in a likelihood this film is
going to be singing in the rain of
course the idea for the movie is said to
have come from chris evans himself and
so evans is not only playing the lead
but also acting as a behind the scenes
producer the studio has not been found
yet though this script has already been
written by alien covenant author john
logan we are definitely looking forward
to further news at the moment evans is
still involved in the shooting of the
latest netflix blockbuster the gray man
so it might take quite a while until the
production of the biopic about gene
kelly will go on
that's it for this week's news be sure
not to miss our latest original on
avatar 2 and get ready for the new movie
year by checking out our compilation on
the new upcoming movies of 2022
happy new year
[Music]